this FedEx store behind me has today
been at the center of what is an
increasingly urgent search for whomever
may be behind the bombings with federal
and local law enforcement focusing on
this and at least two other major
investigative sites as they seek to
bring an end to Austin's terror we've
been working around the clock again the
public safety is our number-one priority
safety that was once again shattered
after another explosion in Texas this
time at a Federal Express facility in
shirt's 20 miles outside of San Antonio
a package had been traveling along the
automated conveyer when it had had
exploded one employee that was standing
near the explosion later complained
complained of ringing in the ears the
FBI believes the parcel was destined for
Austin and are now investigating an
Austin area FedEx store from where they
believe the package was sent this comes
just two days after a blast in the
state's capital injured two men Sunday's
bombing showing what authorities call a
quote higher level of sophistication as
it was triggered by an alien visible
tripwire it was so dark they couldn't
tell any they tripped and set off this
explosion then didn't see it it was a
wire
and it blew up you don't know what to
think which I'm life is happy this John
call for the president echoing that
sentiment and offering support from
Washington the bombings are narced in a
terrible local state and federal of
working hand-in-hand to get to the
bottom of it this is obviously a very
very sick individual or maybe
individuals these are sick people and we
will get to the bottom of it with a
serial bomber at large hundreds of
agents from the ATF and FBI are in the
Lone Star State and racing against time
hoping to stop the person who has killed
two people and injured four others this
month in Austin and who some
investigators believe is likely linked
to today's bomb blast insurance
certainly common sense tells you that it
is very likely connected and I think
we're gonna find out soon that it that
it is connected officials say it is
clear that whomever is doing this has
considerable expertise what isn't clear
is the motive and more frightening Lee
perhaps when and where the bomber will
strike next
Brett Jonathan late this afternoon the
authorities came back and said that that
was not an unexploded device so they
were hoping to get one that was intact
but they came out and kind of corrected
that yes they police chief in shirts
that had originally put out a statement
saying that they had found an device
that did not explode at that large FedEx
facility just outside San Antonio they
walked that back within about two or
three hours and said they had not found
a second device they are still looking
at another FedEx facility here in Austin
near the main airport in the city there
they said that they had found a
suspicious package we do not know at
this hour Brett whether indeed that
contains any explosives Brett will head
back for in breaking details Jonathan
thank you